morning to you boris johnson will today
urge leaders of the world's biggest
economies to make good on their
commitments to cut carbon emissions
ahead of a crucial climate talk in
glasgow as he flew into the g20 summit
in rome the prime minister said team
humanity is 5-1 down at half-time in the
fight against climate change and must
act now before it's too late
president biden is also in rome but is
struggling to get supporting congress to
make good on his climate commitments
our international affairs editor
dominique quaghorn reports from rome
joe biden comes here without a deal
sealed with congress backing his climate
change program and to a g20 that's
divided on the issue
this is what's at stake though
extraordinary floods in sicily a timely
reminder of the urgency of the moment
in the scene straight out of a disaster
movie this week
in balmy sunshine world leaders arrived
in rome for the g20 summit and to a
stern lecture from the un security
general about their failure so far
even if recent pledges were clear and
credible
and there are serious questions about
some of them
we are still careening towards climate
catastrophe
and the best case scenario
temperatures will still rise well above
2 degrees
and that is a disaster
on his flight here prime minister boris
johnson issued twin warnings on climate
change and covert 19. calling on g20
partners to vaccinate the world by the
end of next year
but ahead of the cop 26 climate summit
in glasgow international efforts are
losing momentum not least because
america's president is struggling to
deliver on his agenda
joe biden comes here still needing to
convince allies that america really is
back and leading the free world again
not least on climate change the g20 has
to prove it is united enough to tackle
the climate crisis
i'm the only irishman you've ever met
who's never had a drink
joe biden shared a present and jokes
with the pope but comes here without a
deal sealed at home on his climate
change programme
[Music]
doubts over cop and the g20 are helping
fuel protests ahead of the summits greta
tunberg joining activists in london
and in rome thousands are preparing to
march on the g20 summit among those
gathering at this climate camp there
seemed a growing sense of despair you
have to act now and you have to change
the economic system
otherwise
otherwise it's going to be a disaster
they're really not doing anything it's
getting worse by the minute and
literally we have very few years to come
to stop this we have to stop it right
now
tomorrow is already late every day is
late and
they've been doing they really have been
doing nothing
from rome to glasgow your solutions are
the problem says this banner
world leaders have two days here and two
weeks in scotland to prove that wrong
dominic waghorn sky news row
in just a few minutes i'm going to be
talking to the green msp ross greer in
glasgow about his hopes for the climate
conference
now the queen has been advised by
doctors to rest for more than two weeks
her majesty will not undertake any
official visits during this time but the
palace says it's her firm intention to
attend the annual wreath laying ceremony
at the cenotaph on remembrance sunday
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
reports
remembrance weekend is one of the most
significant moments of the year for the
royal family a time when they all gather
together but we now know the queen is
going to miss the british legion's
festival of remembrance at the royal
albert hall
a statement from the palace said that
following on from their recent advice
that the queen should rest for a few
days her majesty's doctors have advised
that she should continue to rest for at
least the next two weeks the doctors
have advised that her majesty can
continue to undertake light desk-based
duties during this time including some
virtual audiences but not to undertake
any official visits her majesty regrets
that this means she'll be unable to
attend the festival of remembrance on
saturday the 13th of november they
stressed it is still her firm intention
to be at the cenotaph on remembrance
sunday where in recent years prince
charles has placed the nation's wreath
on her behalf
she lived through the second world war
she saw her father lead the nation and
she served herself and for her
this is a prime duty of the monarch
she'll hate missing it but she'll try to
be ready for the remembrance sunday
service
this was the queen's last public outing
a week and a half ago since then she
spent a night in hospital after having
preliminary tests we don't know what for
and canceled two major engagements a
trip to northern ireland and her
appearance at the climate summit in
glasgow
i understand that the queen has been
well enough to record a message that
will be played at cop26 and again the
palace have used that phrase saying that
she is in good spirits they know that
people will understandably be concerned
about her she is after all 95 years old
but they want to stress that doctors are
being cautious and she is still working
away behind the scenes
this week she's welcomed two new
ambassadors to the uk
i'm very glad to have the chance to
see you if only mechanically this
morning
and presented her award for poetry the
queen no doubt also wanting to send a
subtle message of reassurance as she's
so often done during her reign
rhiannon mills sky news at windsor
castle
now prince andrews lawyers in the united
states have asked a judge to dismiss his
accuser virginia geffrey's civil lawsuit
mr freya accused the duke of york of
sexually abusing her when she was 17
more than 20 years ago
in court filings the duke said he
unequivocally denies sexually abusing or
assaulting her
the first group of gay bisexual and
transgender afghans that the uk
government helped flee afghanistan have
arrived in britain the first group of 29
refugees include students and activists
who campaigned for equal rights in
afghanistan many of them would have been
would have been in danger from the
taliban who consider homosexuality a
crime
bristol is the first city in the uk to
launch a program dedicated to tackling
the surge of drink spiking in nightclubs
venues are going to be given testing
kits to help detect harmful substances
and beverages
comes after more than 200 incidents were
reported to police in the last two
months
we started the work back in may with the
police to to develop a response to
drinks viking
and
that developed obviously speeded up
to the position that we're in now where
we've been able to launch a coordinated
campaign that
focuses on
education telling people what what they
can do
and also focuses on the offender about
bringing those people who are committing
the dreadful crime
to justice
now there have been more bitter words in
the dispute with france over fishing
rights the french president emmanuel
macron has accused the uk of breaking
promises it made during brexit talks in
an interview with the financial times he
said when you spend years negotiating a
treaty and then a few months later you
do the opposite of what was decided on
the aspects that suit you the least
it's not a big sign of your credibility
dan whitehead reports from saint helia
on the escalating rail
this could be the last catch of crab to
make it out of jersey
the sarah p has been fishing the
guernsey waters for the last eight days
now the priority is to get it to san
marlo and into the eu
before france blocked ports and toughens
checks
it's very very uh worrying because if
they do close the inspection post down
in somali
we're completely stopped we won't be
able to buy anymore first you won't be
able to export until it's sorted out
we haven't got the option of shipping
through the uk and going out through
holland or going direct to spain the
logistics of it just don't work for us
it's just too far too long too long a
time and it doesn't work
this is jersey's biggest crab and
lobster exporter if they're prevented
from landing their catch in france
there's no point in jersey's fishermen
heading out to sea
the majority of jersey's catch is
exported to the eu so the closure of
ports and extra checks isn't just an
inconvenience it could stop the industry
overnight
the rao centers around licenses and
there are still 55 french boats on
jersey's red list meaning they'll have
no right to fish here from monday
we have
no hint
whatsoever that the boats on the red
list deserve a license in jersey no hint
we've never seen them we've never no
boarded them
nobody
no
justice fisherman has ever seen them
they have no paperwork they have no data
from their gps's that
we have zero
hint that they've been in the area
they're trying their luck
they're trying dollars
tensions escalated after france seized a
scottish scallop trawler on thursday and
charged its captain the crew was seen
leaving the boat surrounded by a legal
team on friday evening
you're heading back to britain tonight
no no no definitely not
it's already does anyone put a date time
on it or is that asking too much
with france threatening to impose
restrictions from tuesday there is
little time to resolve the issue
many of jersey's fishermen are fed up
with the political fighting nobody's
going to win there will be no winners
there will only be losers
but will the french get more licenses
probably just because they're french
the uk says it will respond if france
carries out its threats but prime
minister boris johnson insists france
remains one of the uk's best and oldest
allies
but neither side is backing down
as this diplomatic storm in the channel
continues
dan white said sky news
jersey
the former one direction singer zane
malik has pleaded no contest to
harassment charges after a dispute with
the mother of his girlfriend let's talk
to our reporter casey barnfield what do
we know katie
well indeed the former one direction
star the singer has denied assaulting
yolanda hadid who is of course the
grandmother of his child who had accused
him of
shoving her into a dresser during a
heated argument last month which took
place at the house in pennsylvania that
zane shares with his uh girlfriend the
supermodel gigi hadid and their
one-year-old daughter kai now during
this argument he is alleged to have
sworn at yolanda and ordered her to stay
away from his daughter as well as that
allegation obviously
of physical violence which he denies and
though he does deny the physical element
of it he has as you say chosen not to
contest four counts of harassment
relating to that incident now both zane
and gigi have released separate
statements via american media outlet
zane wanted tmz where he called the
allegations false and then a second
statement on twitter to his 31 million
followers there where he hinted that he
and gigi may have broken up talking
about co-parenting their daughter kai he
said this was and still should be a
private matter but it seems for now
there is divisiveness and despite my
efforts to restore us to a peaceful
family environment that will allow me to
co-parent my daughter in a manner which
she deserves this has been leaked to the
press i am hopeful though for healing
for all involved with the harsh words
shared and more importantly i remain
vigilant to protect kai and give her the
privacy she deserves now in gigi's
statement she released to e news she
didn't directly comment on the
allegations other than to ask for
privacy and say she is solely focused on
the best for kai and the one person we
haven't heard from directly yet is
yolanda herself
okay katie thank you well let's get more
on cop26 and world leaders will begin
arriving in glasgow for the summit this
weekend with the prime minister warning
they must act before it's too late well
let's head to glasgow and talk to ross
greer from the scottish green party good
morning to you i mean first and foremost
are you hopeful that we are going to get
something significant out of cop 26
morning i'm i'm hopeful that we're going
to get something significant i don't
think we're going to get
an agreement a commitment to action on
the scale that we need on on the scale
that the science says is required but i
think we will get something
significant enough that will
basically buy us the time that we need
the the two critical things that we need
out of cop26 are a revised agreement on
the country by country emission targets
in paris in 2015 we set that legally
binding global agreement to limit
warming to 1.5 degrees but the country
by country targets we set would take us
to global warming of about three degrees
so what we need is to revise those
they're called nationally determined
contributions and the second key
objective that needs to come out of this
is honoring the climate financing
agreement we came to in 2009 whereby the
world's richest countries those that
caused the crisis committed to transfer
100 billion dollars a year to the
world's poorest countries by 2020 to
help them adapt and mitigate against the
devastating effects of the climate
crisis
that target wasn't hit we're not even
close to hitting that target by 2020s
the two things that we need from cop are
new country by country emission
reduction targets and a commitment to
actually deliver the money that the
global south needs to deal with the
devastating consequences of climate
breakdown that is already happening
i mean
there's a lot of talk and a lot of
pressure on the prime minister over what
england is doing i mean in the uk as a
whole from from his perspective but also
on what nicola sturgeon is doing what
the scottish government's doing in all
of this and although clearly we are
leaders in this and we are hosting
this event
if
china doesn't play ball i mean
xi jinping not actually attending the
summit if um
president biden can't get congress on
board for his ambitious plans and we're
not going to get anywhere are we
no not at all i mean obviously we need
major emitters like china like the us to
be committing to significant action but
there are positive signs so china for
example has committed to net zero by
2060 and to significant reductions by
2030. now we really need them to go much
further than that but that's significant
progress they've also made specific
commitments for example
against the the financing of coal
outside of china so the chinese
government is one of the major
financiers of new coal developments
across the world it looks like they're
going to end that that's a really
positive step but here in the uk we need
to remember our historical
responsibility here the industrial
revolution started in the uk so
basically we've been emitting a lot more
for a lot longer than pretty much anyone
else on the planet and what we met into
the atmosphere stays there what we
emitted a century ago is still there and
is still a major part of what's causing
this crisis so we have a role here we
need to take a leadership role we have a
moral responsibility and unfortunately
what we've seen from the uk government
in the last week is the opposite of that
if the uk government was serious as the
host of this summit what could be the
most significant summer in human history
they wouldn't have in the last couple of
days made major budget announcements
that included 20 billion pounds on new
roads and cuts to aviation taxes with a
view to trying to increase the number of
domestic fights in this country that's
not climate leadership climate
leadership would be investing in public
transport investing in warmer homes
those are the kind of steps that we're
taking here in scotland but we really
need to say
the head of of scottish tourism has
welcomed that move on flights
i would profoundly disagree with the
scottish tourism alliance on this the
last thing that we need is to increase
domestic fights within the uk what we
should be doing is trying to make rail
travel cheaper in the uk it shouldn't be
up to five times more expensive to take
the trade and say between glasgow and
london than it is to fly we should be
reducing the cost of rail travel we
shouldn't be trying to go back to
pre-pandemic levels of domestic fights
or of international fights because the
climate reality is that we cannot do
that and hit these targets for keeping
global warming to 1.5 degrees you know
we're seeing flash flooding in glasgow
this week that's about as prophetic as
you can get for the host city of a
climate summit just days before the
world arrives we are running out of time
to take the steps that we actually need
to save our planet but these same steps
are ones that would benefit all of us so
in glasgow half of households don't have
access to a private car most of those
households are not flying once a year
never mind on a regular basis cuts to
aviation taxes don't help them making
public transport cheaper more affordable
more accessible so for example in
scotland all young people are going to
be able to take the bus for free from
january next year thanks to a budget
agreement the green party and the
scottish government came to that's
climate leadership and its climate
leadership that actually helps lift
families out of poverty those are the
steps that we need to take not giving
tax cuts to already incredibly wealthy
industries
now in the run-up to the cop 26 climate
talks in glasgow countries have been
encouraged to pledge bold plans to
achieve net zero carbon emissions and
cap global warming at 1.5 degrees
but some nations are still heavily
reliant on polluting industries like
coal and oil
poland for example still gets 70 percent
of its energy from coal and two of the
biggest coal plants turkoff and beckett
off have been resisting calls to comply
with eu emission standards
until they cooperate brussels is finding
the polish government 500 000 euros a
day
stephen murphy has been speaking to
locals in bogota near the turoff plant
poland loves its coal the fossil fuel
generates around three quarters of the
country's electricity and there's a
large and powerful coal lobby
it's dirty it's damaging and it's
divisive as we'll see at cop26 richer
nations want coal gone other countries
think the transition is too fast there's
a lot of opposition here to the eu's
green deal which aims for climate
neutrality by 2050. we went to one coal
mine at turoff to see how the poles are
fighting to exploit their own resources
the tour of mine is the second largest
opencast coal mine in poland and to get
a true sense of its scale you really
need to take to the air it stretches for
more than two and a half thousand
football pitches and the polish
government has now extended its licence
to operate until 2044. the polish are
determined to use those extra years to
take every bit of coal out of the ground
here
[Music]
substantive
it's not just about feeding the power
station here that produces seven percent
of poland's electricity it's also about
the thousands of jobs the mine supports
in the nearby town of bugatinia people
shudder to think
are exploited the mine will creep closer
and closer to the czech border in the
czech village of uhelna residents claim
the encroaching mine is draining their
water
but the crucial area for us
is here and this will be mined in five
years milan sturridge says the water
issue started around the same time the
mine first expanded towards the border
so this is the well this is the old well
or what used to be the well it's uh
it is still well but it's uh completely
empty right now pressure from these
residents led to the czech government
taking poland to the european court of
justice the court ordered the mine to
shut down the polls refused they're now
being fined half a million euro a day by
the court but say the fines won't be
paid moving away from fossil fuels is
painful and in turop's case can drive a
wedge between nations
an education charity says only three out
of every 10 people starting teacher
training this year are men research from
ucas reveals that men are also more
likely to leave the profession after
they've qualified laura bundock reports
on the gender imbalance in schools
a holy semantic field of purity and hope
great answer mr hodges is a class act in
the classroom but as a man he's in the
minority coming over into teaching was a
bit of a a culture shock because it's
about 75 percent you know female why do
you think there aren't more male
teachers i would say kind of the stigma
of the profession as well especially
going into primary school you know that
idea of
stereotypical and outdated concepts of
being a female profession
this year only three in ten starting
teacher training are men but speak to
students and most boys relate more to
male teachers whenever there's
situations or problems they
they imagine themselves in our positions
and they're able to understand like
where i'm coming from male teachers have
a more relaxed um approach to teaching
which i think
suits me better so i think i can learn
more with a male teacher i feel like a
better mix would be better because other
boys would like
be more inclined to choose teaching as
an option as well if they like to
because they see them as role models
10b
is what's happening today
recruitment and retention is hard
especially for male teachers half the
teachers in this school are men but
that's unusual the average secondary
school has just 37 and in primary
schools only 15 percent of teachers are
male
does it matter oasis academy colston has
above average numbers of children from
poorer homes the principal says they
often need positive male role models i
think for students to feel like school
is for them they've got to feel like
they belong
and part of belonging is seeing yourself
reflected in the school community that
you're part of so i think for some of
our working class uh white british boys
it's really important that they can see
people who are not too dissimilar for
them so they can see that as an
opportunity
[Applause]
an opportunity some say could help stop
boys underperforming at school i feel
like there's a lot of kind of positive
momentum
that can come from making sure that boys
don't fall behind in education and i
feel instinctively that having more male
teachers would would contribute
positively to that it seems to me that
seeing
gender equality in you know the first
workplace that young young people really
observe
must be a good thing for gender equality
later in in life macbeth becomes
malevolent and that's why more men in
classrooms might make a difference
helping pupils perform and achieve their
potential laura bundock sky news
coulston in surrey
now he's the american football star who
created a movement when he refused to
stand for the national anthem and
defiance of racial injustice colin in
black and white which is out now on
netflix details the early life of colin
kaepernick through the creative vision
of director eva duvernay
our entertainment reporter claire
gregory reports
[Music]
when american footballer colin
kaepernick refused to stand for the u.s
national anthem in a preseason game back
in 2016 his protest against racial
injustice inspired one of the most
globally recognizable cultural movements
of the century
when i woke up that morning i told
myself i was going to put on a show
now acclaimed director ava duvrenay
gives us the boy behind the man
he came to me with the idea of hey could
i do something with my childhood and so
for me it wasn't um it was it was an
opportunity to say okay we can do this
if if we can use it as a springboard to
talk about much more it's the kid on his
way to being the hero right and it
basically says that we can all be the
heroes of our own lives as long as we
really pay attention to each step
because every step matters the first
time around as many black people
his adoption and nuances of growing up
with white parents would make colin
perhaps particularly culturally aware
my daughter is black and
it's an enormous
sometimes i say the wrong thing
and my son steps in my son's
white uh
but it's his it's her brother and he
is like no mom that's
that's actually not right it's humbling
you know because i also have to be the
mother
but at the same time i have to admit
repeatedly
sometimes i don't know what i'm doing in
certain areas what's up with kaepernick
rather than focusing on the taking of
the knee this examines how the
upbringing of young people can impact on
society
i've been working with kids a lot and so
this work here you know brought me
closer to just an empathy for young
people and the fact that so often
they're told that they're not important
but those moments when you're a teenager
are the most important and so this is
certainly the case with with colin
my passion
my love
was being a quarterback
while there may be some moments from our
childhood that we'd rather forget the
message of this is to pay attention to
young people to shape not just their
future but potentially an entire
movement claire gregory sky news
[Music]
let's have a look at the weather for you
today and it remains unsettled this
weekend yet more wet and windy spells so
there could be a bit more flooding
overnight rain and gusty winds mean a
wet start for much of western britain
should be drier either side of that band
with coastal showers for western ireland
now heavy rain and strong winds will
push north and east into the north sea
leaving a cooler feeling day with sunny
spells and showers those showers most
frequent in the west with a risk of
thunder the rain heavy and slow moving
over parts of scotland but should clear
into the evening
well it's time to take through the
papers this morning with the journalists
afia adam and thomas copeland good to
see you both this morning thomas we'll
start with the i should we and the prime
minister saying cop 26 is
the last chance to save the planet
that's right it's a wide rating
interview with boris johnson in the eye
from the eyes political editor hugo guy
he talks about all sorts of things he
talks about covet the economy booster
jobs supply chains but it's on cop that
i think the weight that we get to the
heart of the issue and most of most of
the interviews spent talking about that
johnson is seems to be on expectation
management mode in the article anyway he
talks repeatedly about how difficult
this is going to be incredibly difficult
he says to get a deal with the countries
around the world attending cop but also
simultaneously raising the stakes
talking about just how significant this
issue is that's where the front page
headline comes from last chance to save
the planet perhaps in the hope that some
of those countries who haven't quite yet
got on board the likes of china the
likes of india it might be at cop that
they or their representatives managed to
get some sort of deal across the line
the two sort of things jump out one
he blasts what could be considered
long-term
um
climate commitments things like 2050
2060. he talks in the article about how
the political leaders making those
commitments will be as he put it's
pushing up the daisies by the time they
ever have to be delivered and actually
quite often it appears to be a strategy
in order to delay action rather than to
set any sort of long-term ambitious
targets perhaps that tell us some tells
us something perhaps that tells us that
a cop we're likely to see some
commitments for the the late 2020s early
2030s as opposed to 40s 50s 60s one of
the other interesting things he talks
about is accountability um he says that
the voters are changing um and even in
countries like russia which is
relatively undemocratic voters are going
green there's a great code in it there's
something more powerful than the
government he says more powerful the
corporations and that's the markets the
market is going green he says my
political supporters are going green so
clearly boris johnson sees you know
tackling climate change head-on as not
only a moral issue that he needs to
address but also an electoral one as
well it's that kind of philosophy that
you know the voters will hold us to a
kind that's embedded in you know
conservatism and liberalism that the
market will decide i wonder though you
know when you've got such an ambitious
project like trying to get
climate change
um
with
trying to mitigate against the effects
of climate change is it enough just to
rely on on voters all the time voters
are capricious they're busy they're
preoccupied with their lives courts and
oversight bodies are not um you know
unless there's some sort of system to
try to make sure that every country is
adhering to their responsibilities and
their commitments is it not the case
that some could start to freeload on the
work of others you know i don't know but
but clearly at the end of cop we'll
start to see if uh that's a philosophy
that bars johnson wants to see through
to the end yeah yeah that's an
interesting point actually um
affia what's the time saying about bowie
yeah so this is a story like you said
from the times and the headline is
200 million pounds sorry 200 million
dollars bid for bowie's songs so of
course we know david bowie a huge hit
maker um and his song the estate of the
song so that's his back catalogue are
attracting bids of 200 million pounds
now the deal would
basically involve um him selling off the
rights and to things like space oddity
his 1970s albums and and basically like
a huge deal for her whoever has the
money who wants to buy these songs so
that would be the publishing and the
recording rights for these david bowie
tracks and this is something you know
the artists do you know they often sell
off their back catalog lauren hill has
done it michael jackson has done it in
the past as well but 200 million dollars
is a pretty high bid for such a huge and
and you know synonymous back catalogue
when it comes to david barry songs and
now we don't know when it will go on
sale and who is bidding at the moment
but if you've got 200 million dollars
you can have them all yeah i wonder who
owns them at the moment
it'll be interesting to know who
actually owns them
i think at the moment it's it's his
estate to own them right yeah oh well i
mean you can understand why people would
do it um to the telegraph thomas uh rail
commuting after that i don't get on the
train very often but whenever when i do
they are extremely quiet at the moment
well that's backed up by the figures
even because uh the rail delivery group
is saying that real commuting to work is
only come up to around 45 of its
pre-pandemic levels weekend journeys
they're back to 90 now what that seems
to tell us is that it's fairly clear
there's been a big shift in working
patterns has happened over the course of
pandemic it looks like we're not just
going back to pre-pandemic life the sort
of rail commuting life we're indeed bus
comedian commuting or any any kind uh
you know jumping on the bus at seven
eight in the morning into the office for
nine jumping on again at five in the
evening it looks like we're not going
back to that that's what these figures
seem to suggest anyway now that's could
be good news and could be bad news the
good news is that um
more working from home flexible working
could be really good for productivity
productivity is the really big problem
one of the really big problems in the uk
economy where we're tied last in the g7
in terms of productivity we're 17th in
the g20 in terms of productivity so if
working from home that means more
comfortable
where you're working less time spent
sitting on a train or a bus greater
flexibility at home maybe it's care
costs maybe it's carrying
responsibilities if all of those things
lead to greater productivity that's good
news for the economy the bad news i
suppose is that the uk as a proportion
of gdp the uk economy is quite reliant
on kind of hospitality stuff like cafes
the lunch places where you get your your
coffees and your food at lunch time and
so if there are fewer people
in city centers where offices would
typically be um purchasing and feeding
money into the economy that way that's
not good news either and it's not good
news i suppose for real companies as
well i mean part of that article is the
real delivery group in some ways
appealing to people get back onto the
trains they seem to be saying so you
know it's good news and bad news my
feeling is that the productivity will
edge it that's better for the uk economy
but only if i suppose we can come to a
position where people are at the
weekends jumping on the train or going
into the town centers and injecting
money into the economy that way as well
so um it remains to be seen long way to
go but potentially some good news for
productivity yeah it's interesting isn't
it how they what the long-term effects
of the pandemic are going to be in terms
of how we change as a as a country and
as a as an economy um now let's look at
the ft
uh affair because there's always this
argument isn't there you know are you
uh are you an apple or are you a
microsoft sort of person microsoft
winning the deal at the minute
yes they are now i'm usually an apple
type of person but like so many other
people i have been forced to use
microsoft teams over the past two years
um and that has helped them get to some
record profit so their profits are up
5.5
yesterday making them um the biggest
company uh the biggest tech company
enlisted they've overtaken apple at the
moment and so and that of course their
growth is because of the use of
microsoft products over the pandemic and
probably microsoft teams and all the
rest of the things that enabled us
enabled us to work virtually remotely
and digitally and so apple also have um
fallen fell to the market at the moment
and they are down about four percent at
the moment and slow sales of the new
iphones new ipads the new apple products
and shortages when they're trying to get
chips i've also heart iphone as well and
this is a week where you saw telsa at
tesla excuse me on the market you know
another trillion dollar company as they
were declared